alice has one of the most
interesting backstories of all of the
cullens with her father plotting to get
rid of her and throwing her in an asylum
but why didn't any of that make it into
the twilight movies
alice cullen's backstory is so
incredibly rich and interesting
that it inspired a collection of short
films the films were part of a fan
contest
and the best entry was the mary alice
brandon file
which highlighted alice's traumatic
childhood and her journey to becoming
one of the most
powerful vampires in the world as you've
gathered from the title
alice was born mary alice brandon and
her childhood was
anything but easy however those troubles
make alice's optimism and energy
even more inspiring but there are many
things that the twilight movies gloss
over when it comes to potentially the
most
interesting of all the cullen siblings
the way alice grew up gives us a deeper
look into how she developed such a close
bond with edward
and how she was able to use her visions
to become a vegetarian even before she
met her adoptive vampire family
while leaving her story out of the films
was in large part due to time
constraints
and how much work it would have taken to
tell the story properly
there are a few other issues like the
fact that alice barely remembers her
life as a human
in case you're also a bit fuzzy on what
that was like let's give a quick recap
of the life of mary alice brandon before
we get into what her story really means
to the series
and what we finally learn about her in
midnight sun
oh and if you haven't seen all the
movies or read the books there are
definite spoilers ahead
alice was born into a middle class home
in biloxi mississippi
in 1901 to a jeweler father and a
stay-at-home mom
alice had already had premonitions since
she was a child but they weren't nearly
as exact as they would become when she
turned into a vampire
people in her small town weren't big
fans of her because whenever she tried
to warn them about her unfortunate
predictions they would think her mad
and call her a wick
one day alice had a vision of her
mother's tragic passing and tried to
warn her
her mother actually believed her but her
father didn't
father it wasn't an accident enough for
your stories
eventually whoever was after her got her
and it was declared an accident
within six months alice's father
remarried a new woman who hated alice
but loved her little sister cynthia
alice had a vision of her father
planning to get rid of her
like what happened to her mother alice
rushed to the town's marshall for help
but her father had already told everyone
she was crazy
see this is what i was telling you
she's insane she ended up getting sent
to an asylum
while in the asylum she literally lost
her mind
she endured electroshock therapy which
gave her amnesia
but while there she also met a
mysterious and friendly vampire who
treated her like a daughter
he would even hide things in his hands
to test her psychic abilities
but eventually alice had another
troubling vision
this time about a powerful tracker
hunting her down
this tracker was james alice informed
her vampire friend
and realizing that there was really no
way out of this
she decided to let him change her the
vampire did and hid her away going off
to distract james but he ended up
sacrificing himself to buy alice more
time
james decided to just let her turn since
she was already well into the process
and then alice was a vampire the bite
did have some negative effects
the pain was so bad that alice lost her
memories all over again
but her premonitions were also
intensified and she saw both jasper
whitlock
and her future with the cullen family
since she had this heads up
she was able to adopt a vampiric
vegetarian lifestyle
all on her own she finally met jasper at
an empty diner in philadelphia in 1948
and helped him adopt a vegetarian
lifestyle too
and in 1950 they joined the cullens
eclipse gives fans a look into jasper
and rosalie's lives before they met
carlisle
and midnight sun gives even more insight
into what carlisle himself went through
but in terms of rich vampire backstories
that's about it explaining alice's
backstory would have meant a lot more
scenes and a lot more characters
so ultimately the film's decided not to
include it but there's enough stuff
there that alice could have had her very
own movie
as demonstrated by the short film
instead the movies focused on alice's
bond with jasper and the formation of
the cullens
alice's complicated backstory would have
given us a better sense of just
how much self-control this self-taught
vamp vegetarian really has
she literally had no one to help her
figure things out
except her own visions of the future
these visions gave her incredible
strength
and that strength is found in the will
to do hard things and steer herself
towards the right path
because she knows that that's ultimately
where she has to end up
it's easy to be upset that we never got
a good look into alice's amazing inner
strength and just how much she protects
the cullens with her visions
but it also kind of makes sense that the
movies wouldn't want to take the time to
show us all this
after all alice doesn't really remember
her life as a human so she wouldn't
really be able to discuss her past
in depth and none of the cullens were
there to witness her history
at least breaking dawn part 2 did find a
way to highlight alice's importance with
that huge vampire werewolf battle
that turned out to just be one of
alice's visions this moment gives us an
idea
of just how powerful these visions can
be and what would happen to the cullens
if they didn't have alice to point them
in the right direction
alice's story would have given us a
greater sense of her bond with edward
though
and that's probably the aspect that
would have made the most sense to
include
in the movies both alice and edward bond
over something invisible their
supernatural abilities are understated
in the sense that they can see or hear
things that no one else can
there's a huge burden that comes with
having supernatural abilities that help
them
but also take away everything that's
mysterious about life
it's the burden of knowing on top of the
burden of immortality
but even if we didn't get to see this
bond play out more explicitly in the
movies we did get some deeper insight
into how it affects edward analysis
relationship in midnight sun
the biggest revelation from midnight sun
is that edward knew pretty much from the
start that bella was
probably going to become a vampire
that's because he can read
alice's mind and see her visions which
include the possibilities of him turning
bella
leaving her or losing her completely the
way alice's visions work is by providing
all potential futures so edward and
alice work together to figure out what
could protect bella and how turning her
might actually work when edward takes
bella to the meadow
he knows that he could be overcome with
bloodlust but he's able to push through
it
this knowledge lets us finally
understand some of edward's
indecisiveness when it comes to bella
and why he always seemed so conservative
kept holding himself back and second
guessing his actions
but edward never told bella this and
didn't want alice to tell her either
so that she would still have some free
will on the flip side
this shows us that alice and edward have
very little free will of their own
if this had been included in the movies
we would have been able to see
just how much alice affected edward and
bella's relationship
and we might have further sympathized
with edward's inner turmoil
edward decides by the end of midnight
sun to live in the present
and resist the urge to peek into alice's
visions i didn't look into the future
it was enough that i could feel it
coming when i promised her forever now
i meant as far as i could see but that
doesn't keep him from knowing a bit too
much
and acting on it like when he decides to
leave bella in new moon
edward might be able to try and ignore
alice's visions but midnight sun just
further emphasizes the burden of seeing
the future
and it's something that alice can't
avoid whether we finally get a
full-length film about alice or not
it's important to recognize that she's
one of the most constantly tormented
members of the cullen family
yet she still has a bright sunshiny
attitude and in a lot of ways
keeps the family together and acts as
their protector maybe one day we'll get
a movie about alice's history or
even a sequel centered on her but for
now we can continue to read between the
lines and appreciate
just how much alice truly means to her
vampire family
and how much she overcame to get there
do you think alice cullen deserves her
own movie
should ashley greene reprise her role
let us know what you think in the
comments
don't forget to click that like button
if you enjoyed this video and subscribe
to our channel for more
thanks for watching